sur la toile c'est un début
d'indignation depuis ce mardi des
comptes twitter relais un message de
didier rahout ce tweet dans lequel le
professeur cite les résultats
préliminaires de l'étude discovery des
résultats qui selon lui prouveraient que
sa molécule fétiche l'hydroxyte leur
quine serait bel et bien efficace pour
rappel l'hydroxyte l'euro qui n'avait
été sortie de l'étude discovery à la
suite d'un article frauduleux du land
sept avant d'être réintégré une fois la
fraude avérée pour être définitivement
abandonnée peu après car jugées
inefficaces injustement donc selon
didier rahout et depuis plane un soupçon
de délit d' injustice autour de
l'hydroxyte eurokin un traitement peu
onéreux que l'on chercherait à enterrer
par favoritisme envers la big pharma
problème des données partielles
concernant lé hydroxy chloroquine
avaient déjà été publiés dans un autre
tweet par nathan piper smadja
infectiologues interne à l'ap-hp et qui
lui prétend que l'étude discovery
démontre l'inefficacité de l'hydroxyte
l'euro qui est ce que vous avez remarqué
les deux tweets qui se contredisent
illustrent leurs propos à l'aide de la
même image des mêmes chiffres
rigoureusement si l'on en croit donc
l'interprétation de ces chiffres par les
deux infectiologues l'hydroxyde
chloroquine est à la fois efficace et
inefficace alors qui croire
la question se pose en fait
régulièrement au gré de la publication
des études scientifiques
ici une étude italienne qui démontre
l'efficacité de la molécule là une étude
belge qui parvient aux mêmes conclusions
mais là une méta étude qui prétend l'
inverse
on ne sait plus quoi penser et ça tombe
bien c'est comme ça que la science
fonctionne sauf qu'on l'a oublié cela
fait sept mois que l'on dit à peu près
tout et son contraire sur l'hydroxyde
chloroquine com à propos de didier raoul
tour à tour mais si génial victime du
complot politico pharma tic au parisien
ou bien escrocs fer de lance de la
dissidence marseillaise uniquement guidé
par une quête de gloire personnelle et
bien entendu ce relais dans les médias
les partisans des deux camps des invités
plus ou moins concernés et aussi il faut
le dire plus ou moins compétents parce
que pour appréhender les résultats d'une
étude et pour juger de sa crédibilité
encore faut-il savoir ce qu'est un
protocole d'essai clinique un essai
randomisé
un groupe contrôle un test en double
aveugle en effet placebo ce que signifie
la pi value à notre ratio un rapport de
risque un risque relatif à un intervalle
de confiance et j'en passe vous ne
maîtrisez pas tous ces termes je vous
rassure la plupart de ceux qui
s'expriment tout de même sur le sujet
n'ont plus cette période de crise
sanitaire aura aussi été celle de
l'ultra crépy d'ariane isme un terme
savant récemment popularisé par etienne
klein qui désigne le fait de parler d'un
sujet pour lequel on n'a aucune
compétence nous nous jetons tous depuis
plus d'un semestre sur la moindre étude
portant sur l'idh roxy chloroquine sur
le dernier article à propos de didier
rahout ou du coc vide 19 en oubliant que
notre compétence en la matière est loin
d'être suffisante pour alimenter
sainement tout débat scientifique car la
science a besoin de temps et de patience
pour avancer depuis sept mois il semble
que le temps scientifique et rejoint le
temps politique et médiatique
un temps qui ne permet pas à la science
d'exprimer un consensus et sans
consensus
la science devient un acte de foi et si
vous vous souvenez de giordano bruno et
de galilée foi et science font rarement
bon ménage